these see questions despite how
different they look actually the same
question keidel so let me explain how
and why people are having issues with
this right let's start with three I have
a look at it it looks fairly innocuous
doesn't look like you can do much to you
what would you like me to do from y1 to
y2 I think expanding makes sense right
because if you expand this it'll talk to
the other side so you get 4x I say
equals 4x plus and then and then the
cogs start to turn easy I can what do I
do to the next life think about all of
the rules of how you deal with
acquaintances what can you do to the
next life you could you can rearrange it
in some way right except you run into a
teeny little problem right in fact I've
got to do my tree arrangement at all I
noticed that both sides have a 4x on
them right so normal thing to do would
be to get all the X's on one side so
let's get all the extras off here what
am I gonna have to do to get rid of all
the extras over here I'm gonna have to
subtract 4x to both sides
except how many X's that leave me do on
the left
none of them so that leaves you with the
API and the 9 and you're like oh no you
guys it's not even we haven't had the
bolt belt or Roku yet another a big
matter ok so what is going on rewind a
little bit this is why don't have pens
in your hands I just want you to think
when I asked you to solve an equation a
beginning of the day what did it mean
what were you searching for in terms of
this life a solution is a value of x
such if you if you put it in the first
line it all it'll work it'll be true
right problem is if we agree that line 1
and line 2 are the same game just
dressed up differently payoff
then there is no value of x that you can
ever put into this thing don't we'll
make it
what do you agree with that whatever
that if X you choose 1/3 a million
negative five okay these two objects
here 4x and 4x on both sides always be
the same whatever they are and then
you're left with these two bits that are
different okay now this is very very
easy to illustrate if you think about
this visually you remember all of those
other things that I showed you before
like these things right to try and
convince you
visual proofs are very helpful can
someone tell me what does that look like
I know I've introduced this Y so to help
us solve the question but you can graph
this straight line you've been able to
do it for years now what is it how are
you - spider can you give me some words
to use to describe what is um what's
that for tell you it was you the
gradient so for is that steep or shallow
or going up going down what is it it's
going up and skyrocketing right so Bruce
Lee what about this 8 we're going it's
the y-intercept so it's something like
this
so I think that's a reasonable graph of
y equals 4x plus 8 this happens to be
negative 2 okay now think thing if I now
ask you to graph y equals 4x plus 9
again it's got that 4x which tells you
the gradient again what's the
relationship between the gradient of
this line and 4x plus 9
it's the same right if two lines have
the same gradient that means that they
are parallel to each other except
there's just this difference here it's
been a beautiful unit you train there's
something like that
okay they only say if that's 4x plus 9
and that's 4x Plus 8 what this line is
saying is hey tell me where they are
equal where they collide with each other
where they intersect and whether they
intersect and sup they never do so
therefore there's no solution
ok now I've just enough time to explain
why this question is the same question
but in Reverse I'm going to take the
same suggestion we had before right
which is to say let's expand this table
okay
so they're 10 times going to give me and
my hand sides gonna give me 2x plus 2
and then another X you guys are bright
I'm gonna do that one line I'm gonna say
3x plus 2
now pause think think that's a dangerous
line and once you look at this line
again just like you looked at this line
what this is asking is what is this
thing less than this thing well you
remember how I said to you before I
don't care what actually put in there
it'll never be true never ever ever in a
million years this is the same thing
except the other way around because you
can put any X you like in there right
put an x equals 1 1 take away 3 negative
2 1 plus 2 that's 3 that's less than
that is it - it isn't what do you think
yes wait which is still true isn't it
it's negative 3 yes okay right wow
that's great isn't it bad that's still
true okay good all right give me another
number
don't move when x equals zero when x
equals negative 5 these things are
always going to be true okay you
remember how DWP do you remember I drew
them can you tell me what 3 X minus 3
looks like it's it intersects down here
and it goes up right do you agree with
that that happens it's a new one
ok what's that kind of like again it's
parallel except it's high up so what
this is saying is when is this line
below this line it's up everywhere all
values of X